vou mostrar aqui minha vida como era
antes de ser famoso e depois ser famoso
eu escovando os dentes
Eu famoso escovando os dentes
eu vendo alguém comendo alguma coisa
antes de ser famoso
dançar um pouquinho vou começar um
pouquinho só com colheradinha Não dou
não eu vendo alguém comendo alguma coisa
depois de famosos
vou começar um pouquinho só a
colheradinha não mas lógico tem coisas
que mudaram não vou ficar
tudo igual ai humildade humildade por
exemplo agora tem uma chance de viajar
pelo mundo conhecer o mundo as outras
línguas antigamente eu errava só o
português ela fala nós vai nós foi agora
eu erro em espanhol eu erro em inglês eu
tenho tantas língua variedades para
errar eu conheci meus ídolo eu conheci o
Tom Cavalcante cara o Tom Cavalcante o
Tirulipa que agora se tornou Meu Amigo
Luan Santana cara eu conhecia